[Musik]
arkadien einer der schönsten
landschaften chiles die gegend wird
chilenische schweiz genannt wegen der
berge aber auch weil ende des
neunzehnten jahrhunderts 22.000
schweizer hierher ausgewandert sind
doch die idylle täuscht die nachfahren
der schweizer siedler werden bedruckt
[Musik]
die matsche indianer die indigene
bevölkerung fordern von ihnen das land
zurück
der rückgewinnung des landes können wir
unsere wirtschaftliche situation
verbessern
die natur schützen und unsere
traditionelle lebensweise wiederfinden
wir wollen ein würdiges leben führen die
siedler sollen in ihrer länder zurück
sie sind nicht von hier wie aber schon
die siedler haben das land urbar gemacht
jetzt nach fünf generationen sollen sie
alles aufgeben
aufgeben ist nicht unser ziel
darum sind wir hier viele freunde von
uns sagen immer was macht ihr da aber
das ist unser land
februar erntezeit in chile
ewald luchsinger und sein bruder harald
bewirtschaften die santa rosa 60
hektaren gross die schweizer sind stolz
auf ihren besitz stolz auf das was ihre
vorfeld aufgebaut haben
doch das land auf dem sie leben wollen
ihn die nachbarn wegnehmen es sind
mabuse indianer ureinwohner der region
einige von ihnen arbeiten als
erntehelfer auf den feldern der luchs
ines akkordarbeit zu minimallöhne andere
mappus behaupten das land gehöre ihnen
und nicht den schweizern
wir halten also eine langfristige gute
relation mit ihnen
wir sind als familie hier in diesem
sektor von jahre 1908 mehr oder weniger
so das sind über 100 jahre dass wir ein
1 1 1 1 boden verhängt haben das ist was
wir von glahn ausgekannt haben nichts
anderes darum ist für uns sehr sehr
schwer zu verstehen wieso das auf den
gekommen ist
[Applaus]
die arbeit auf der farm ist gefährlich
geworden
seit 2009 wurde die santa rosa immer
wieder angegriffen
es brennt es darstellung maschinen zeiss
was weiß ich bis auf dem talent
damit die maschinen der wirtschaftliche
schaden ist enorm
die familie ist in ihrer existenz
bedroht die luchsinger sutton 2 120
milchkühe
heute stehen die stallungen leer
sie mussten alle ihre spiele verkaufen
2015 ist bei einem anschlag einer
molkerei völlig abgebrannt wenn man ein
betrieb hat und das zerstört wird
dann haben wir nichts mehr da haben wir
nun schon seinen banken da muss man
wieder mal von neuem anfangen sagen was
mache jetzt meine eltern leben noch und
mein vater hat immer gesagt ich verkaufe
nicht und bei dem soll es auch bleiben
und doch die looks singers sind auf dem
rückzug
die eltern der brüder haben den hof
verlassen aus angst vor anschlägen
seewald noch harald trauen sich
einzuziehen
in der stadt leben
das ist natürlich ein bisschen grausam
eigentlich aber die realität
die polizei bewacht das wohnhaus rund um
die uhr sieben tage die woche
seit fünf jahren steht es leer
spuren des letzten angriff
in diese richtung wurde geschossen die
angreifer hatten benzinkanister dabei
sie wollten das haus abbrennen
drinnen sieht es noch so aus wie an dem
tag als die eltern das haus verließen
[Musik]
hier sind wir im wohnzimmer kamin
da haben wir eine familien button das
haben wir dann in holz machen lassen
haben wir natürlich aus der schweiz
gebracht wie die skizze und das wurde
hier von einer passage gebaut gemacht
die familie stammt aus annie kanton
glarus waren hauptsächlich landwirte und
sind dem jahre 1883 nach die cdu viele
gekommen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der bus aus der regionalhauptstadt dem
co
wie
einmal pro woche kaufte die familie
dräger in der stadt ein
dinge die sie zu hause auf der farm
nicht produzieren können die trucks
gehören zu den mappus familien die um
die rückgabe von land kämpfen
wann der älteste sohn trägt die
verantwortung für die familie
er ist 26 und studierte geologie mit den
luxus streiten die drei ks bald 20 jahre
erst ging es um wasserrechte dann ums
land viel zeit für die arbeit auf dem
hochplateau an wegen des studiums nicht
der familie mangelt es an allem die zehn
hektar an land werfen zu wenig ab um
davon leben zu können mit einfachen
handwerksarbeiten verdienen sie sich
etwas dazu der kampf ums land ist ein
kampf um die existenz
er wird hart ausgetragen das land gehört
unseren vorfahren
es steht eigentlich uns zu
ich bin aber dagegen dass man familien
mit rot der und ihnen gewalt antut
viele mappus sind nicht damit
einverstanden
doch die zerstörung von maschinen
unser land kaputt machen diese form von
gewalt ist eine reaktion auf die gewalt
des staates
die frauen verarbeiten die wolle der
eigenen scharfe aroma und maria teilen
sich die aufgabe zwei frauen ein
haushalt bei den apache ist es nicht
ungewöhnlich dass ein mann mit zwei
frauen lebt maria wänden potro für
umgerechnet 375 franken verkaufen
ein lächerlicher preis bei einem
arbeitsaufwand von mehreren wochen
so wird die familie nie der armut
entkommen
deutsche sind immer noch auch anders als
die siedler haben wir kein kapital für
investitionen
sie sind mit nichts aber die regierung
hat sie unterstützt was sie aufgebaut
haben haben sie nicht aus eigener kraft
geschafft
heute besitzen sie viele maschinen und
haben arbeitskräfte
[Musik]
arkadien ist die kornkammer chiles das
haben die siedler geschafft im
neunzehnten jahrhundert hat der
chilenische staat sie an geworden
deutsche franzosen italiener und 22.000
schweizer sie haben das noch wilder land
für den jungen dänischen staat urbar
gemacht
[Musik]
die looks singers gehörten zu den ersten
siedlern
heute besitzen sie mehrere farmen sie
sind durch die landwirtschaft zu
wohlstand gekommen
wenn sie gemeinsam feiern wird deutlich
die einwanderer familie von einst ist zu
einer sippe angewachsen
[Musik]
die jüngsten sprechen meist nur noch
spanisch die älteren mehr oder weniger
gut deutsch der schweizer dialekt ist
verloren
bestenfalls bleiben ein paar brocken
doch der schweiz fühlen sie sich noch
sehr verbunden
zum fest haben sie fotos mitgebracht
dokumente von der ansiedlung in der
neuen welt
[Musik]
das erste haus die familie hat es noch
selbst gebaut
diakon jaguar das schiff auf dem die
siedler einen monat reiste
der vertrag mit dem chilenischen staat
40 hektaren land für jeden segler und
urvater sebastian wenige jahre zuvor
hatte er mit seiner familie die schweiz
aus armut verlassen aus emi im kanton
glarus kam die familie in chile gelangte
sie rasch zu wohlstand die looks singers
kauften neues land hinzu und zogen in
zweiter generation in die gegend von
temuco die brüder lockruf bis 1000 oder
100 metern bis da sie gekauft
die frauen meckern das ist immer immer
mehr ländern eingekauft wurde für fast
nichts
die luxus und wie sie viele andere
siedler werden reicher und reicher
die mappus dagegen verarmen heute
fordern sie das geraubte lang zurück
land das die siedler seit 140 jahren
bewirtschaften sie stolz auf ihre
geschichte der erklärung
also für uns ist nichts geschenkt nichts
und der einzige der verantwortlich ist
das ist jetzt passiert ist unser start
er hat kolonisiert härte klimaschutzes
in kleinen flächen getrennt und her hat
das rest des landes versteigert
jetzt stehen die luxus im zentrum des
konflikts
besonders hart traf es volker andreß
2013 wurden seine eltern opfer eines
anschlags genau in dem haus in dem sie
heute feiern die polizei zeichnete den
notruf auf ich bin wenig später beim
haus angekommen auf dem weg habe ich
gesehen dass das haus in flammen steht
dass der brand in der küche ausgebrochen
ich glaube dass sich die angreifer ganz
knapp verpasst habe ich habe meine mama
gesucht die mich vor wenigen minuten
angerufen nachdem wir sie die ganze
nacht gesucht hatten haben wir am morgen
erfahren dass zwei körper im haus
gefunden wurden
es war bereits völlig abgebrannt
entgegen unserer hoffnung bestätigte
sich das ist die überreste man eltern
waren
[Musik]
das elternhaus haben woche andress und
seine brüder wieder aufgebaut
niemand wohnt mehr darin es dient der
familie als ort der zusammenkunft und es
ist eine botschaft an die täter ihr
könnt alles niederbrennen
ihr könnt uns töten aber euer ziel
werdet ihr nicht erreichen
für den anschlag auf das ehepaar
luchsinger werden drei matuschek
verantwortlich gemacht einer der
verurteilten ist ihr vater jose trucker
in einem ersten verfahren wurde er
freigesprochen
doch die regierung legte berufung ein
und dann wurde er zu 18 jahren gefängnis
verurteilt
josef ackerl entzog sich der haft durch
flucht für die brüder ist klar
ihr vater ist opfer einer großen intrige
es sind neun personen angeklagt worden
alles personen die andere führen können
und die über das wissen die fähigkeit
verfügen land ansprüche gegen den staat
durchzusetzen
es ging um das land der siedler
ganz besonders im fall der luchsinger
nur deswegen wollte man sie wegsperren
man hat die leute für den mord an dem
ehepaar verantwortlich gemacht die für
die rechte der mappus
tatsache ist ihr vater rosetta gall war
einer der führenden köpfe im land streit
er hatte sich mit dem alten porträt
luchsinger jahrzehntelang gestritten
tatsache ist auch im ersten verfahren
wurden die von der polizei vorgelegten
beweise wegen des verdacht auf
manipulation abgewiesen
für die kinder ist daher klar
der prozess ist eine verschwörung des
staates gegen ihren vater
[Applaus]
[Musik]
rusalka die mappus sehen in ihm einen
märtyrer im kampf für die rechte ihres
volkes sein verteidiger kommt wie immer
zu fuß
matschie verteidigen ist kein
einträgliches geschäft pablo ortega kann
nach dem urteil des obersten
gerichtshofs in chile nicht mehr viel
für die drei ks tun
deswegen will er an den inter
amerikanischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte
da sieht er weit bessere chancen ebay
habe im prozess ein gesetz aus der zeit
der pinot chat diktatur angewandt das
sogenannte anti terror gesetz das
schränke die rechte der verteidigung
stark ein und es verstoße klar gegen
international geltende normen das gesetz
gegen den terrorismus kino chat benutzt
um die demonstranten festzunehmen die
sich für soziale rechte stark gemacht
und eben dieses gesetz wird jetzt im
konflikt mit den macho angewandt mit dem
gleichen maßstab dem gesetz vom kino
chat wird heute gegen die gemeinde der
mappus hervorgegangen pablo geht noch
einen schritt weiter
chile habe ein politisches urteil
gefällt das unter dem druck der siedler
zustande gekommen sei
joja sohn ihr dürft heute sind die
nachfahren der grossgrundbesitzer auf
allen ebenen der gesellschaft vertreten
in den gerichten der polizei und der
administration
sie bestimmen über die sicht der dinge
die mappus haben keine chance sich
dagegen durchzusetzen
der graben könnte nicht tiefer sein
bablok data sieht sich im kampf gegen
eine justiz die das recht der
herrschenden vertritt die sec million
ist in einer ähnlichen situation
ihr mann luis trenker wurde ebenfalls zu
18 jahren verurteilt und ist flüchtig
auch ihre familie kämpfte gegen vt
luchsinger neun jahre haben sie mit ihm
umland gerungen wollte lippi setzt auf
einen teil des land stücks das zuvor
horche gehörte doch reset will mir es
gibt noch viele maputo familien die kein
land haben der kampf unseres volkes ist
noch nicht vorbei und genau deswegen
sind die truck als verurteilt worden
es ist rein politisch besonders valeries
denn er hat begonnen das landgut eines
anderen look singers zurückzuerobern
es geht um uns als gemeinschaft
wir haben das anrecht auf ein würdiges
leben die siedler sollen in ihre länder
zurückgehen sie sind nicht von hier
wir aber sind von hier
diese sucht nicht einfach den
persönlichen gewinn
vielmehr geht es ihr darum ein
historisches unrecht rückgängig zu
machen
sie ist stolz auf ihre identität als
macho
sie kleidet sich traditionell und rüstet
weizen nach altem brauch
diese nimmt auch eigenes leid in kauf
etwa dass die kinder ohne vater
aufwachsen
gewalt ist für sie ein legitimes mittel
wenn man die siedler vertreiben bin muss
man sie an ihrem wunden punkt treffen
das ist die wirtschaftskraft deswegen
hat man angefangen die ernte abzubrennen
und ihre rinder zu töten
doch man muss wissen dass die gewalt
zuerst vom staat ausgegangen ist gegen
das volk der mappus
der staat hat die siedler hergebracht
der staat hat mit der pacifica zion von
aragonien den krieg angefangen und uns
gezwungen in kleinen gebieten zu leben
dass sie wie kation befriedung nennt es
die offizielle geschichtsschreibung
beschönigend für die matsche bedeutete
es besetzung und unterwerfung
der chilenische staat nahm den
halbnomaden 90 prozent ihres
territoriums und vechte sie in reservate
mit dem land ging ihre lebensweise
verloren
mit der neuen gegebenheiten kamen die
mappus nicht zurecht das land das ihnen
der staat gab war schlecht und anders
als die siedler bekamen sie keine
unterstützung
das einst wohlhabende volk der mapuche
verarmte zu sehen
[Musik]
was macht das volk der mapuche in dieser
situation die mappe üben
selbstverteidigung zur strategie der
selbstverteidigung gehört politische
gewalt wie wir es nennen
im zentrum der politischen gewalt steht
der boykott unterbot verstehen wir
aktionen die sich gegen die
wirtschaftliche macht der siedler
richten gegen forstwirtschaft und
bergbau gegen alle unternehmungen die
unsere ressourcen ausbeuten
die matsche haben sich in der geschichte
erfolgreich gegen die inka und die
spanischen konquistadoren gewährt die
selbst sieht sich in dieser tradition
[Musik]
ein paar kilometer entfernt hatte andrés
seine farm
er hat junge rebstöcke angepflanzt
deswegen lässt er nach wasser bohren
er braucht es fürs haus und die reden
auch seine farm wird rund um die uhr von
der polizei bewacht woche lebt seit
jahrzehnten mit der bedrohung durch die
matte und erkennt ihre forderung nach
mehr land die armut der mabuse hier auf
dem land ist unübersehbar
man muss sich in ihre position
hineinversetzen
aber ich kann den weg der gewalt nicht
akzeptieren wenn sich die höfe abbrennen
oder die ernte und wenn sie menschen so
vergelten sie unrecht mit unrecht einen
wichtigen grund für die gewalt sieht
rache andrés im ley in die rinne
das gesetz regelt die rückgabe von land
an die matsche eine wiedergutmachung des
staates für die historische schuld aber
das gesetz ist schlecht durchdacht das
gesetz fördert gewalt es unterstützt
landkäufe ausgerechnet dann wenn ein
konflikt bestellt deswegen wurden in den
letzten jahren bewusst konflikte
geschürt
auf der anderen seite werden die
benachteiligt die rechtmäßig vorgehen
feuer einfällt ist abgebrannt
im februar wenn der sommer auf der
südhalbkugel zu ende geht ist die natur
völlig ausgetrocknet
feuer brechen in dieser jahreszeit
regelmäßig aus eine unachtsamkeit genügt
selbstentzündung ist möglich oder aber
brandstiftung ist der grund
[Musik]
auch die weizenfelder von nektar urban
brennen immer wieder in diesem fall
breitete sich das feuer rasend schnell
aus die bauernfamilie konnte es knapp
vor den wohnhäusern stoppen
[Musik]
ewald hat vom anschlag erfahren und ist
gekommen um sich den schaden beim
befreundeten bauern anzusehen
die arbeit von einem ganzen jahr
roth und sophie es nicht brauchen
es war der rest der ernte acht anschläge
hatten die urbans allein dieses jahr
insgesamt 46 hektaren mit weizen sind
abgebrannt
kaum zu glauben dass die familie da
nicht aufgibt wir haben keine andere
wahl
das oder nichts wir können nirgends hin
wir sind an das land gebunden das ist
das einzige was wir haben und um hier
wegzukommen müssten wir es verkaufen
aber niemand würde es kaufen
als betroffene familie die in diesem
konflikt steckt fühlen wir uns vom
chilenischen staat betrogen denn der
chilenische staat ist ins ausland
gegangen und in die schweiz nach
deutschland frankreich und italien um
leute zu rekrutieren
damit sie hier arbeiten und die nation
groß machen
temuco hauptstadt der region und
kommerzielles zentrum
auf dem markt verkaufen china putsche
der umgebung ihre produkte
hier kommen sie zusammen deutsche sieht
schweitzer sieht und matt kuchar
wenn sie sich in einem punkt einig sind
dann darin
der staat hat seine bürger betrogen er
trägt die schuld am konflikt nie hat er
sich ernsthaft bemüht das zusammenleben
zwischen den bevölkerungsgruppen zu
harmonisieren
er hat sie gegeneinander ausgespielt und
lässt sie heute in ihrem kampf allein
im geschäftsviertel der stadt ist ewald
unterwegs
[Musik]
er hat sich längst ein zweites standbein
aufgebaut als immobilienmakler
über jahre waren vor allem die looks
singers im fokus der anschläge
viele sagen weil die looks singers die
mappus besonders schlecht behandelt
hätten
ewald hat eine andere erklärung wir sind
auch natürlich von der lage exponiert
weil wir wie wir sie sehen hier gibt's
denn natürlich ein großes geländes an
der realität das ist genau inmitten der
homo ja erstmal putsches die ringsherum
also sind sind ständige probleme
tagtäglicher probleme und das macht
ihnen die arbeit ziemlich schwer
so war mal das bei uns so mit kühen und
grafik war
und so ist es also was ist eigentlich
ein schuppen wo wir wo wir das
fotomaterial hatten
da wurde es so wollen
die finger heben dann geschlachtet war
also nur um schaden zu machen eigentlich
[Musik]
längst sind die luxus nicht mehr die
einzigen opfer
die anschläge richten sich gegen
zahlreiche institutionen der
gesellschaft
ewald führt uns zurück die gremien dem
verband der lokalen wirtschaft
der verband will frieden für die region
frieden für ihn heißt der staat muss
härter durchgreifen als bisher der tod
und die ermordung des ehepaars
luchsinger macke in ihrem haus sind das
resultat schrankenloser gewalt der staat
ist unfähig bestens bekannte
gruppierungen zu bestrafen
von der polizei über die geheimdienste
bis zu den richter ist er unfähig
urteile zu fällen die täter ein für alle
mal fest
erster casas zeigt uns wie stark die
anschläge im letzten jahr zugenommen
haben
der streit um das land bedrohe die
chilenische gesellschaft als ganzes
deswegen unterstützt mirka saß die
anwendung des anti terror gesetzes das
aus der zeit der diktatur von keynotes
stammt schluss damit
wir haben nichts mit ihnen zu tun das
gesetz verschafft sicherheit im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert es
ermöglicht informationsbeschaffung was
die angriffe radikaler gewalttätige
gruppierungen auf ihre mitbürger
verhindert
sie nehmen
mit pino chat die matsche unterdrücken
mit dem ley indiana gewalt belohnen
der staat hat es versäumt das problem
grundsätzlich anzugehen
hin und hergerissen zwischen politischen
interessengruppen entfernt sich schiene
von einer lösung anstatt ihr näher zu
kommen
ewald bringt uns zu einer frauengruppe
dieser will landesweit aufmerksamkeit
für ihre probleme schaffen
anschläge auf höhere gewalt gegen ihre
kinder leben in permanenter angst
hallo 400 mitglieder zählt die gruppe
eine deutschstämmige bäuerin ist bereit
mit uns zu reden
ihre namen sollen wir nicht nennen zu
oft werde ihre gruppe als rechts
abqualifiziert hier gehe es um die
familie in ruhe groß werden dass sie
nicht wegziehen müssen das ist die
heimat hier
die angriffe in der region hat sie in
einem kalender aufgezeichnet als gruppe
vulkania sahen wir dass wir das in der
presse und dass die leute in santiago
von dieser ganzen sache nichts wissen
wenn wir uns überlegt wie machen wir das
damit die leute das visuell mal schnell
sehen und dann sind wir zu dieser idee
gekommen und nun haben wir ein kalender
inside 2016
das resultat ist dramatisch es gibt im
monat mehr tage mit anschlägen als tage
ohne natürlich ist das ein angriff auf
ihr hab und gut je nachdem sogar auf ihr
leben
trotzdem die frage warum es in
verständnis dafür dass noch punktet
sagen wir wollen länder zurück die man
uns früher mal genommen hat ich habe es
am anfang verstanden aber jetzt haben
sie so viel länger rein und haben soviel
die blinden und hilfe bekommen und das
steht dass es jetzt unproduktives land
ich bin landwirt in ja und wenn ich sehe
dass da jetzt nur monika und nichts
angebaut wird
verstehe ich das nicht
der vorwurf an die matsche sie seien
faul und unproduktiv kommt häufig von
seiten der siedler
doch was für die siedler faulheit ist
ist für die matsche leben in harmonie
mit der natur
es geht um die beziehung der matsche zur
erde
es geht um das gleichgewicht wie lassen
der erde zeit sich zu erholen
wir fangen nicht an wälder flüsse seen
oder küstenlandschaften zu verändern
wir respektieren die natur so wie sie
ist
denn wir wissen dass auch andere tiere
sie als lebensraum benötigt dimap ute
machen sich anders als die christen die
erde nicht untertan
sie sehen sie als ein ganzes und sich
selbst als ein teil davon
die natur ist für die mappus beseelt es
gibt einen ort wo sich die nieren
aufhalten
sie sind die hüter der erde sie sind
geistwesen auch unsere vorfahren
signieren
[Musik]
man muss eine tiefe beziehung zur erde
aufbauen man muss tief im innern
erkennen will linien sind ohne sie
verlieren wir die beziehung zur natur
es gibt sehr viele nicht mehr als
menschen
wir menschen lieben kurz die drei wollen
an einem ort gehen muss ich ihnen
aufhalten
sie bitten um erlaubnis sie klagen
demian dass sie fälschlicherweise
beschuldigt werden für dein tod an den
look singers als geschenk streuen sie
mail ins wasser für die mappus aber
immer die natur des paradies wir wollen
keine großen dinge schaffen denn die
bauwerke der natur sind bedeutender als
die bauwerke der menschen
deswegen gibt es bei dem mappus anders
als bei den azteken und mayas keine
großartigen bauwerke
mit der kolonisation haben wir uns von
der natur entfernt wenn wir nun unseren
lebensraum zurückgewinnen finden wir
zurück zu den pflanzen zum glauben zur
sprache und spiritualität
[Musik]
der heilige ort ein natürlicher
unberührter wald
[Musik]
hier gibt es zahlreiche pflanzen und
kräuter über deren nutzen irma und maria
gut bescheid wissen
wenn du krank bist sagte der hüter des
waldes in einem traum welches heilmittel
du brauchst
denn du bist ein mensch ein mensch der
erde dann suchen wir das heilmittel und
wenn wir es finden wenn wir ihm ein
gebiet dann gehen wir nach hause um die
medizin zuzubereiten
und schon bevor du das heilmittel zu
bereit ist fühlst du dich gut
man nimmt uns mit zu säcke denn er ist
der longo der traditionelle führer der
mappus gemeinde
er ist aber auch professor für
geschichte an der katholischen
universität von temuco kurse ist
überzeugt die matsche müssen identität
und stolz wieder finden um zu ihren
rechten zu kommen
wir hatten keine rechte mehr kein recht
auf bildung kein recht auf medizinische
versorgung kein recht auf würde das wird
nicht aufhören solange wir uns als
mappus nicht wiederfinden den macho
wurde alles genommen
besonders hervorgetan hätten sich dabei
die luchsinger als sie sich hier in der
region niederließen noch lustig energie
und ab und die luxus hatten ein
lebensmittelgeschäft erhalte konrad lux
er sah dass die leute hunger haben und
hat ihnen lebensmittel angeboten wie sie
etwas zu essen
die leute konnten nicht bezahlen und
haben sich immer weiter verschuldet dann
ist er mit polizisten gekommen
er hat ihre tiere genommen ihr hab und
gut und schließlich auch irland
man muss nur frage mit wie viel hektar
land haben sie begonnen und wie viel
land haben sie heute
auf dem familienfest konfrontieren wie
solche mit der geschichte das halte ich
nichts von bayern nichts überhaupt
nichts
also sie damals sehen und gucken
alles was die luchsinger vom staat
bekommen wurde bezahlt als sie haben
kein land bekommen sondern immer nur
gekauft von nichts
kein quadratmeter von von mappus ist das
war alle privatunternehmer also private
bauern ja ob wahr oder nicht die
geschichte klebt an der luxus und macht
sie zum bevorzugten ziel von angriffen
das bekommt auch die junge generation zu
spüren
ich gehe nicht gerne auf die straße weil
es gefährlich ist
jemand könnte mir was antut
zum beispiel an der universität wenn wir
studenten über solche themen sprechen
kann ich nicht stellung beziehen
weil es zu gefährlich ist so wie er habe
auch ich probleme an meiner schule hätte
mikko es gibt mitschüler die firma
putsches sind und solche die gegen
einmal wurde ich betone ich bin in die
schule gekommen und an der wand stand
heraus mit den look singers tod den look
singers luchsen joyce die tochter von
horch anderes muster jahrelang unter
polizeischutz zur schule gehen
trotzdem sie möchte auf dem land bleiben
ich will das würde ich kinder habe dass
meine kinder auf die anderen aber haben
genug
seit wir fünf jahre als sind leben wir
hier mit dem konflikt wir haben die nase
voll davon
[Musik]
als kinder haben wir viele geschichten
gehört
erfüllt von hass aber wir hassen
niemanden
das bringt doch eine zukunft auf dem
land sehen wir nicht sie sind gut
ausgebildet und haben wenig interesse an
der landwirtschaft
der kampf der eltern macht für die
nächste generation kaum mehr sinn
[Applaus]
anders ist die situation bei den mappus
sie sehen die chance ihr schicksal
selbst in die hand zu nehmen
am rad marke machen sie es vor kein
sponsor bestimmt über das festival keine
polizei passt auf auch die familie
dräger ist dabei wann und seine
geschwister verdienen hier geld geld für
den geplanten prozess am inter
amerikanischen gerichtshof sie wollen
den vater zurück wenn jemand zu so
vielen jahren verurteilt wird ist das
als ob er gestorben wäre
der vater fehlt in der familie erzählt
den kindern
er fehlt dem haus und auf dem feld das
ist hart und wir wissen dass er
unschuldig ist
[Musik]
ein staat der sie kriminalisiert und
diskriminiert sie fühlen sich
ausgestoßen und wollen eine eigene
autonome gesellschaft
dahinten dokument
abseits der großen bühne treffen sich in
einem zelt politisch aktive mappus sie
diskutieren über das leben in der
gemeinde über politik und neue formen
des befreiungskampfes es ist ein
parlament ein ort des gesprächs des
austausches der meinungsbildung
die leute haben über ihre erfahrungen im
befreiungskampf erzählt und ihre meinung
zur aktuellen situation ausgetauscht
ich denke der anlass ist wichtig wir
sollten damit weitermachen und mehr
leute dafür gewinnen erst müssen wir
miteinander diskutieren und dann handeln
das ist der richtige weg
[Musik]
fest und politik gehen fließend
ineinander über
woran hat es noch einen auftritt
die verurteilung von pause entließ sei
weit mehr als ein schlag gegen die
familie trageser das urteil ein angriff
auf das volk der matte
[Applaus]
es war ein ungerechtes urteil im fall
luchsinger makaay gegen unsere brüder
die trucker sie sind auf der flucht vor
der rassistischen chilenischen regierung
aber wir werden den kampf für unsere
freiheit für autonomie und
selbstbestimmung weiterführen sie
kämpfen für die unabhängigkeit von dem
staat der uns so lange unterdrückt hat
freiheit für unser land freiheit für
louis und gus ithaka
[Applaus]
zehn tage nach dem auftritt von clown
und seinen geschwistern werden korsett
raggal und louis trucker von der polizei
gefasst
[Musik]
die politik des chilenischen staat
gegenüber den mappus ist bis heute
widersprüchlich weder die linke noch die
rechte haben eine schlüssige lösung zu
bieten
der kampf ums land geht weiter